[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen nach dem Hilferuf kommen
jetzt die Schuldzuweisungen und ein
echter Streit in heftigem Tonfall
zwischen dem Bund in dieser
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und den
Bundesländern es geht um aber Milliarden
an Finanzhilfen für geflüchtete deren
Zahl immer weiter steigt der Bund muss
mehr zahlen sagen die Länder der Bund
zahlt bereits mehr als nötig sagt der
Bund es geht neben dem Geld aber um noch
viel mehr nämlich um die Frage wie die
künftige Migrationspolitik in diesem
Land aussehen soll angesichts einer Lage
in Europa die zum Handeln drängt aber
Europas Regierungen wie gelernt
erscheinen lässt noch zwei Tage bis zum
großen flüchtlingsgipfel in Berlin Frank
Buchwald Bilder aus Bensheim aber es
könnte überall sein Städte und Gemeinden
wissen nicht mehr wie sie die
Flüchtlinge unterbringen sollen seit
Wochen schlagen Bürgermeister Alarm der
Landrat des Main-Kinzig-Kreises geht nun
einen Schritt weiter er klagt gegen den
geltenden Verteilungsschlüssel
egal ob in den Ballungszentren oder in
den ländlichen Gebieten alle haben
momentan die Probleme die Versorgung die
Unterbringung von geflüchteten von
Asylsuchenden am Ende auch zu
bewerkstelligen so dann kann es am Ende
nicht sein dass hier dann noch mal sage
ich mal der Ausländeranteil von Menschen
die teilweise seit Jahren seit Jahrzehnt
und einfach ihr Leben nur in anderen
Pass haben hier am Ende noch mit
angerechnet werden der Landrat verklagt
seit eigenes Land Hessen die
Ministerpräsidenten aber rufen selbst um
Hilfe es geht um Milliarden aus Berlin
ich strebe anders wir zurückkehren zu
einer pro kopfberechnung insoweit kann
man natürlich jetzt keine starre Zahlen
nennen aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass
wir fast von einer Verdoppelung der
derzeitigen Zahlen sprechen müssen mehr
Geld für die Länder aber das sei nicht
drin sagt der Finanzminister
der Bund leistet ja Milliardenbeträge
zur Unterstützung der Länder und der
Gemeinden jetzt steht aber anderes im
Zentrum wir brauchen eine andere
Flüchtlingspolitik wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass es weniger irreguläre
Migration nach Deutschland gibt und dass
die Menschen die kein Aufenthaltsrecht
hier haben unser Land auch wieder
verlassen Mittwoch treffen sich die
Ministerpräsidenten deshalb mit dem
Kanzler grundlage der Gespräche ein
Beschlussvorschlag danach soll es
künftig mehr Abschiebungen geben der
illegal eingereist ist könnte ihn
Abschiebehaft genommen werden aus
zentralen ankunftseinrichtungen könnten
Flüchtlinge die kein Bleiberecht haben
direkt abgeschoben werden für die Grünen
nicht vorstellbar das ist ein Revival
eine Horst seehofischen Innenpolitik
also wo auf ähm wo zwar
Rechtstaatlichkeit eingeschränkt wird
aber am Ende kein einziges Problem
gelöst wird das wird es nicht geben die
SPD kennt zwar die Nöte der
Bürgermeister verweist aber auf den
Fachkräftemangel und plädiert für
bessere Integration Ziel
mit einer Asylpolitik der Europäischen
Union die derzeit ja weiterentwickelt
werden soll ähm auch mehr Ordnung
reinzubringen wir brauchen Zuwanderung
das muss man ganz deutlich sagen egal
wohin man schaut der Weg über Europa für
die Linke ist das keine Lösung
Europa macht dicht und die SPD macht mit
und dafür bekommt bundesinnenministerin
Weser ja folgerichtig auch Lob von ihrem
Vorgängern nämlich von Horst Seehofer
der ja vor einer restriktive und
unmenschliche Flüchtlingspolitik bekannt
war das klassische Dilemma zwischen
Menschlichkeit und Möglichkeiten die
Gemeinden aber müssen damit umgehen und
es kann am Ende nicht sein dass die
kommunale Familie das Städte und
Gemeinden hier immer wieder als
Bittsteller behandelt werden wer soll
kommen wer muss gehen Fragen an einen
Einwanderungsland das lange keines sein
wollte
der Vorsitzende der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist ein
Niedersachsen derzeit der
spd-ministerpräsident in Hannover guten
Abend Stefan weil sie was grüß sie weil
da stehen Bund und Länder jetzt
gegeneinander werfen sich gegenseitig
vor nicht die Wahrheit zu sagen was soll
denn wir Bürgerinnen und Bürger davon
halten ja ich bin nicht sehr glücklich
mit dieser Situation da mache ich gar
keinen Hehl daraus es ist nur einfach so
dass wir als Länder in diesem Fall nicht
in erster Linie für eigene Interessen
unterwegs sind sondern wir sehen uns das
sieht auch die Verfassung sofort vor
allen Dingen als Sachwalter für die
Kommunen und die haben es wirklich
schwer und wir müssen Vorsorge dafür
treffen dass die kommunenhandlungsfähig
bleiben denn wir brauchen sie auch in
der Zukunft die Kommunen sind diejenigen
für die wir diese Auseinandersetzungen
aller erster Linie führen
um mal gleiche inhaltlich zu reden sie
wollen weg jetzt von einer Pauschale die
Sie aktuell aus Berlin bekommen wieder
hin zu einem Betrag je Flüchtling genau
das sagt die Bundesregierung hatten die
Länder allerdings vor zwei Jahren noch
abgelehnt ist es so dass sie mal so mal
so machen je nachdem was ihn jetzt
gerade mehr Geld bringt aber nein wir
haben im Herbst eine
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit dem
Bundeskanzler gehabt hat der Bundestag
der Bund von sich ausgesagt er will zu
diesem Pauschalsystem wir haben uns als
Länder dagegen kräftig gewehrt wir
hatten leider keinen Erfolg und das
Minister was wir erzielen konnten war
dann reden wir um Ostern herum weiter
weil wir glauben nicht dass sich das
bewährt und ich diese Prognose war
richtig wir sehen zum Beispiel bei der
Zahl der Asylsuchenden auch in den
ersten drei Monaten dieses Jahres wieder
einer erhebliche Steigerung und wenn das
so ausgeht da kann man sich ausmalen was
das heißt für die Kommunen aber auch
gerade in finanzieller Hinsicht jetzt
sieht das der Regierungssprecher
allerdings heute anders er erzählt es
heute zumindest anders war die Faktor
ist es so dass wir auf der einen Seite
wir sehen ganz viele Papiere ist eine
Papier kommt von der Bundesregierung das
andere wird dann quasi dagegen
geschrieben von dem Ministerpräsidentin
und Ministerpräsidenten der Streit wird
heftig ausgetragen harter Tonfall ist
das so dass Föderalismus aktuell in
Deutschland wenn wir erinnern an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenzen zu
gaspreisdecke und in Corona Zeiten da
hat man irgendwie den Eindruck der
Föderalismus für zu einem nämlich zu
Streit
also sowohl durch Corona wie durch die
gaspreiskrise sind wir in Deutschland
gut durchgekommen auch im
internationalen Vergleich aber noch
einmal die Situation die wir jetzt haben
die haben wir nicht haben wollen es ist
der Bund gewesen der auf einer Zahlen
Grundlage die in vielerlei Hinsicht
angreifbar ist in der letzten Woche da
gewissermaßen eine Informationskampagne
eröffnet hat und man kann von den
Ländern nicht erwarten dass sie das
widerspruchslos akzeptieren das Papier
auf dass die sich auf dass sie sich eben
beziehen das Stamm von unseren
Haushaltsexperten die verstehen auch
sehr sehr viel von der Sache und ich
muss sagen am Ende des Tages wünsche ich
mir dass wir vor allen Dingen weniger
über die einzelne Zahl reden sondern
über den Grundsatz wir müssen zu einem
atmenden System kommen wir können das
Risiko wachsender Zahlen nicht den
Kommunen überlassen die Bundesregierung
ignoriert die Lage vor Ort weitgehend
sie tut die Hilfe rufe ab sagt ihr
Amtskollege wüst aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
warum tut ihr Parteifreund Olaf Scholz
dass
nun jeder von uns hat sein eigenes
Temperament mit dem er sich ausdrückt
wir hatten heute am Vormittag eine
Videokonferenz mit den
kommunalspitzenverbänden und da ist uns
noch mal sehr sehr nachdrücklich gesagt
worden das ist gerade in dieser Zeit
jetzt auf der kommunalen Seite sehr
genau beachtet wird ob der Staat
tatsächlich auch unterstützt der Punkt
ist noch einmal dass wir doch den
Kommunen nicht diese Unsicherheit
aufbürden möchten und nicht können wenn
die Zahl von Asylsuchenden singt was ja
sehr erfreulich wäre dann werden auch
Länder und Bund weniger zahlen aber wenn
sie steigt dann muss auch der Bund sich
beteiligen ebenso wie die Länder ja
derzeit mit kräftigen Zuwachsraten dabei
sind das ist der Grundsatz um den es
geht jetzt aber weil nicht nur ums Geld
es geht auch um einen grundlegenden
Kurswechsel in der Asylpolitik so wie
die zumindest die FDP eine Zeitenwende
sagt sie in der Migrationspolitik und
auch interessanterweise kommt auch aus
ihrer Partei und dem Kanzleramt selbst
dazu jetzt deutlich schärfer schöner als
in der Vergangenheit da geht es um
längere Abschiebehaft deutlich mehr
Abschiebungen die möglich sein sollen
Aufnahmezentren an den EU-Außengrenzen
das klingt alles nach Horst Seehofer
also das was insbesondere die
Bundesregierung auf europäischer Ebene
vor hat das ist nur wirklich zu begrüßen
eine stärkere Grenzsicherung und es ist
auch richtig wenn man versucht die
Asylverfahren direkt dann beim
Grenzübertritt durchzuführen
und versucht durchzusetzen und es hat
überhaupt nicht geklappt wie wir wissen
genau und deswegen können wir auch nur
die Bundesregierung darin unterstützen
aber wir kennen uns kennen uns nicht
darauf verlassen dass ihr Erfolg haben
wird und wir können das erst recht nicht
darauf verlassen dass die Zahlen
daraufhin nachhaltig zurückgehen können
und deswegen können wir das eine nämlich
das Thema Wie sieht künftig das
Asylverfahren aus nicht gewissermaßen
eintauschen gegen das andere nämlich die
Frage der finanziellen Belastung jetzt
sagt Entschuldigung sagt die
Bundesregierung auch die Länder müssten
ihre Hausaufgaben machen und zwar
inhaltlich gesehen weg vom Geld und zum
Beispiel schneller werden bei der
Abschiebung ist das ein Schuh den sie
sich anziehen naja wie fast überall
können wir bei der Digitalisierung in
Deutschland natürlich auch in dieser
Hinsicht besser werden und da sind die
Länder auch tatsächlich motiviert und
umgekehrt kann der Bund durch eine
Modernisierung des Ausländergesetzes
nachhaltig dazu beitragen dass die
Ausländerstellen weniger Arbeit haben
dass die Menschen dort weniger belastet
sind ich weiß gar nicht ob es Sinn macht
dass wir uns gegenseitig jetzt der die
Bälle hin und her werfen tatsächlich ist
das worüber wir reden eine gemeinsame
Aufgabe und der sollten uns auch
gemeinsam stellen gut sie sagen es macht
nicht so viel Sinn sich die Bälle hin
und her zu werfen aber sie werfen
natürlich den Ball auch ganz schön
Richtung Berlin jetzt ist am Mittwoch
der Gipfel und die Frage die sich ja
stellt auch angesichts der
Migrationspolitik in Europa die nach
Meinung vieler nicht nur Trauerspiel
sondern eine Schande ist kommt man da
wenigstens auf deutscher Basis auf
deutscher Ebene zu einem konkreten
Ergebnis haben sie den Eindruck am
Mittwoch gibt's einen Durchbruch
also das halte ich jedenfalls für
möglich dass wir bei den Themen die ich
da vorziehen zitiert hatte gemeinsam
zueinander kommen und es ist tatsächlich
so das war schon 2015/16 der Fall und
das ist jetzt wieder der Fall dass wir
natürlich auch die Folgen einer man muss
sagen nicht vorhandenen europaweiten
Migrationspolitik zu spüren bekommen nur
sie werden verstehen dass die Kommunen
und die Länder leider keine Möglichkeit
haben das zu beeinflussen wir können die
Bundesregierung sehr gerne unterstützen
aber den Erfolg wird in dieser Hinsicht
wahrscheinlich selbst dabei führen
müssen und wenn am Mittwoch keine
Einigung gibt sondern weiter hin und her
und gegenseitig die Schuld zuschieben
wer wird am Ende davon profitieren ja
ich fürchte diejenigen mit denen weder
der bunten noch die Landesregierung
etwas zu tun haben wollen diejenigen die
versuchen Ausländer Angst und Ausländer
Hass zu schüren dazu zählen wir alle
nicht und deswegen bin ich auch
definitiv nicht zufrieden mit der
Situation die wir jetzt haben ich
wünsche mir deutlich eine Idee
Eskalation dass wir vernünftig
miteinander reden und dass der Bund
bitteschön reflektiert wie diese
Situation in den Städten und gemein ist
ich komme an den Anfang zurück das ist
das was uns treibt sagt der SPD
Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen
Stefan weil vielen Dank gerne tschüss
das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen kurz vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet zu alledem kommen etwa
eine Million Menschen die aus der
Ukraine zu uns geflüchtet waren wie
viele davon exakt noch in Deutschland
leben ist nicht ganz klar weil sie keine
Anerkennung als Asylbewerber brauchen es
dürften nach wie vor sehr viele sein in
deren Heimat heute wieder die Sirenen
losging weil Russland eine groß
angelegte Angriffswelle gestartet hat
aus Kiew Tim Krüger
die Angriffe haben mehrere Regionen in
der Ukraine zum Ziel hier in Odessa geht
ein Lebensmittellager in Flammen auf
dutzende Raketen und Drohnen sind
unterwegs mehr als 30 allein über Kiew
so Bürgermeister Vitali Klitschko alle
sein gestoppt worden aber die
herabfallenden Trümmerteile richten
erheblichen Schaden an
war heute eine massive Attacke auf
unserer Heimatstadt 36 Kamikaze Drohnen
flogen in unsere Richtung aber dank der
Luftabwehrsysteme sind alle abgeschossen
einmal mehr verbreiten russische Drohnen
und Raketen Terror unter den Menschen in
der Ukraine
ich konnte nichts machen ich habe im
Korridor hinter zwei Wänden Schutz
gesucht
mehr kann ich leider nicht sagen
wann wird das alles enden das Schlimmste
ist dass wir bereits gelernt haben damit
zu leben wir sind morgens aufgestanden
haben das Kind zur Schule gebracht es
ist beängstigend
heftige Attacken laut ukrainischer Seite
auch in der seit Monaten umkämpften
statt bachmut Russland wolle die Stadt
unbedingt noch vor dem morgigen neunten
mai einnehmen jenem symbolträchtigen Tag
an dem in Russland die Kapitulation
Deutschlands begangen wird dafür setzen
sie nach Angaben der Ukraine auch
verbotene Phosphor und brandmunition ein
nach ZDF Recherchen ist die Stadt da
unten bachmut die internetaufnahmen sind
nicht älter als drei Tage trotz der
massiven Attacken gibt sich der
ukrainische Präsident selenski Sieges
gewiss
wir haben damals gekämpft und bekämpfen
jetzt so dass niemals wieder jemand
anderer unterdrückt und andere Länder
zerstört das alte Böse das Russland
jetzt zurückbringt wird besiegt genauso
wie der Nationalsozialismus besiegt
wurde
Buderus
und silenski legt einen Gesetzentwurf
vor Deutschland Kapitulation soll
künftig in der Ukraine mit einem
offiziellen Feiertag am 8 Mai und nicht
wie in Russland am 9 mai begangen werden
während sie dort schon für die
Militärparade üben wird
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen morgen in der Ukraine erwartet
heute ist der 8 mai für Deutschland ein
Tag zum Inhalt halten Hannah du hast
mehr dazu in der Nachrichtenübersicht
ganz genau in Deutschland wurde heute
vielerorts an das Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs und die Befreiung vom
Nationalsozialismus vor 78 Jahren
erinnert an der zentralen Gedenkstätte
neue Wache gedacht der ukrainische
Botschafter marcelef und der Regierende
Bürgermeister Wegner der Opfer von
Kriegen und Gewaltherrschaft vor dem
Hintergrund des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine hatte
darauf verzichtet Grenze an sowjetischen
Ehrenmalen niederzulegen
außerdem haben sich heute in Weimar über
1.000 Menschen versammelt um gegen einen
Auftritt von Thüringens afd-chef höcke
zu demonstrieren schon im Vorfeld war
dessen Rede im Rahmen eines sogenannten
montagsspaziergangs kritisiert worden
Jens Christian Wagner Direktor der
KZ-Gedenkstätte Buchenwald die ganz in
der Nähe von Weimar liegt bezeichnete
höckes Auftritt am Tag des
kriegsgedenkens als geschichtspolitische
Provokation
die chinesische Regierung hat
überraschend ein Treffen von
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner mit seinem
Amtskollegen Leo Kunden in Peking
abgesagt laut Ministerium wegen Termin
Gründen bei dem für Mittwoch geplanten
Besuch sollten eigentlich die deutsche
chinesischen Regierungskonsultationen
vorbereitet werden das Treffen sollen
nun zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
stattfinden der chinesische
Außenministerin Gang wird unterdessen
morgen zu einem spontanen Besuch in
Berlin erwartet und wird dort unter
anderem Außenministerin Bernburg treffen
nach einem mutmaßlich rassistischen
Vorfall in einer Ferienanlage in
Brandenburg ermittelt nun der
Staatsschutz wegen des Vorwurfs der
Volksverhetzung eine Gruppe
Zehntklässler aus Berlin hatte am
Wochenende ihren Aufenthalt abgebrochen
nachdem sie nicht nur fremdenfeindlich
beleidigt sondern auch bedroht worden
sein soll von dort Feiernden teils
vermummten Jugendlichen die Polizei
begleitete die Abreise der Berliner
Schülerinnen und Schüler und denen die
meisten einen Migrationshintergrund
haben
es ist die wichtigste Wahl des Jahres
sagt das internationale
Nachrichtenmagazin die Economist am
kommenden Wochenende wählt die Türkei
ein neues Parlament und einen
Präsidenten und es sieht so aus als ob
der bisherige dauerpräsident bangen muss
um sein Amt halb Erdogan steht enorm
unter Druck und seine politischen Gegner
sagen genau deshalb ist es jetzt so
wichtig dafür zu sorgen dass diese Wahl
korrekt abläuft hunderttausende
freiwillig sollen direkt an den
wahlordnen aufpassen auch weil in den
vom Erdbeben verwüsteten Regionen die
Wahl noch mal zusätzlich brisant ist
Anna falls mit mehr
das ist Zuhal Aslan
seit dem schweren Beben in der Türkei
gilt sie als vermisst
wenn wir sie nur tot finden würden dann
hätten wir zumindest Gewissheit es ist
so schwer
was bleibt von der geliebten Tochter die
Handtasche konnte aus den Trümmern
geborgen werden und ein Stimmzettel eine
Wahlberechtigung hinterlegt beim
dorfversteher ihm bereiten genau diese
Stimmzettel Bauchschmerzen Burak winzert
ist ein adiaman der Vorsitzende der CHP
der führenden Oppositionspartei in der
Türkei und das sind nicht nur die
Wahlberechtigung der Vermissten die zum
Problem werden könnten das größte
Problem sind die die tot sind Ihre Daten
stehen noch im Wahlregister die
Befürchtung auch die Stimmzettel der
Toten könnten missbraucht werden um wie
viele Stimmen es genau geht ist unklar
denn offizielle Zahlen sprechen von mehr
als 6000 Toten Burak bin seit gerechnet
aber mit mindestens 40.000 allein hier
in Adaman
also tote die wählen wir wollen mehr
darüber erfahren Verabredung mit zwei
vorstehen aus der Region sie zeigen uns
die Wahllisten
tatsächlich stehen hier mehrere Personen
die beim Erdbeben gestorben sind die
dorf-vorsteher werden die Namen von der
Liste löschen lassen am Wahltag
aufpassen dass kein Stimmzettel eines
Toten in der Wahlurne landet hier sei
das möglich
in meinem Wahlbezirk gibt es 330 Wähler
ich kenne jeden von ihnen aber ein
adiaman zum Beispiel gibt es Viertel mit
10.000 WLAN dort kann nicht jeder jeden
kennen die könnten betrügen die könnten
sicher schummeln
die damit ist die AKP die Partei
Erdogans gemeint wir fragen nach bei dem
Mutter dem Statthalter eines Bezirks in
adiaman der zur AKP gehört der Mann ist
zuständig für mehr als 6000 Menschen er
weiß den Vorwurf der möglichen
Wahlmanipulation zurück
seit 15 Jahren bin ich Bezirksvorsteher
ich weiß wer tot ist und wer nicht sie
kennen wirklich alle Menschen hier also
alle nicht aber hier weiß man einfach ob
es diese Person gibt oder nicht
darauf nicht verlassen
sondern der Vergangenheit kam es zu
schwerem Wahlbetrug dieses Mal werden
wir das versuchen zu verhindern indem
wir alle Vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen
sie haben deshalb hunderttausende
freiwillige im ganzen Land angeheuert
Menschen aus der Region die aufpassen
sollen dass weder Stimmzettel von
vermissten noch von Toten abgegeben
werden
am Sonntag kommt das heute schon mal
live aus Ankara mit allem was Sie wissen
müssen rund um diese Wahl des Jahres
jetzt erstmal noch mal hier aus Mainz du
Hanna die Organisation für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung hat heute ihre Prüfberichte
für Deutschland vorgelegt Wirtschaft und
Umwelt stehen dabei im Fokus und neben
lob gibt es darin auch eine Reihe
deutlicher Appelle Richtung
Bundesregierung fragwidmann blicken wir
zuerst auf den Klimaschutz denn hier
sieht die OECD akuten Handlungsbedarf
inwiefern genau weil Deutschland zu
langsam sei wenn man sein ehrgeiziges
Klimaziel erreichen nämlich bis 2045
klimaneutral zu werden da muss das Tempo
der Energiewende deutlich erhöht
verdreifacht werden sagt die OECD sie
nennt Beispiele vom Ziel 15 Millionen
Elektrofahrzeuge und eine Millionen
Ladepunkte bis 20 30 da die
Bundesregierung sehr weit entfernt laut
OECD müsste Deutschland die Aufgaben
effizienter angehen
Dienstwagenprivileg oder
Entfernungspauschale würden falsche
Anreize setzen sagt die Organisation
stattdessen sollte die Ampel unter
anderem die öffentlichen Investitionen
die Schiene erhöhen und dafür sorgen
dass die Bahn weiter an Attraktivität
gewinnt welches Zeugnis hat die OECD
Deutschland denn mit Blick auf die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung ausgestellt
da fallen die Noten besser aus laut OECD
rutscht Deutschland nicht in eine
Rezession die Belebung der
Auslandsnachfrage und hohe
Auftragsbestände sorgen für eine
allmähliche Konjunkturerholung die OECD
lobt sogar Deutschlands rasche Reaktion
auf die Energiekrise man habe die
Abhängigkeit von Russland rapide
verringern können noch besser aber
könnte es laufen wenn die Deutschen
länger arbeiten würden effektiv scheiden
zu viele Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer zu früh aus dem
Erwerbsleben aus eine weitere
Stellschraube an der man drehen muss die
Entbürokratisierung in der Verwaltung
vielen Dank für diese Einordnung
die aktuell diskutierte vier Tage Woche
trifft bei Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern auf große Zustimmung
allerdings nur bei vollem Lohnausgleich
das zeigt eine aktuelle Umfrage der
Hans-Böckler-Stiftung demnach könnten
sich 73% der Befragten vorstellen ihre
Arbeitszeit zu reduzieren wenn dies
keine Lohnkürzungen bedeutet lediglich
8% würden eine geringere Bezahlung in
Kauf nehmen die Befragten die sich eine
vier Tage Woche wünschen würden nannten
als Gründe vor allem mehr Zeit für sich
selbst und für ihre Familie
im Westen Kanadas kämpft die Feuerwehr
weiter gegen mehr als 100 Waldbrände
fast 30.000 Menschen mussten bereits
ihre Häuser verlassen einzelne
Regenschauer in der Provinz Alberta
haben die Lage bisher kaum verbessert
wegen der hohen Flammen und der starken
Rauchentwicklung konnten die
Einsatzkräfte noch nicht überall hin
vordringen das Ausmaß der Schäden lässt
sich noch nicht abschätzen
sie gehörte zu den legendären
Opernsängerinnen des 20 Jahrhunderts und
galt als Wegbereiterin für schwarze
Künstlerinnen im klassikbereich nun ist
die US-amerikanische mezzo Sopranistin
und Sopranistin Grace bambreak gestorben
mit ihrer Darstellung der Venus schrieb
Bambi 1961 in Bayreuth Operngeschichte
als erste schwarze Sängerin die bei den
Wagner Festspielen auftrat über 50 Jahre
lang sagen sie an den großen
Konzerthäusern weltweit und war bekannt
für ihre ausdrucksvolle Stimme und
leidenschaftliche Bühnenpräsenz
86 Jahre alt
[Musik]
wer heute auf den Mount Everest will
kann diverse Touren buchen im Basislager
gibt es sogar eine Sauna und wird dabei
scharenweise andere Touris treffen die
auch auf den Mount Everest wollen heute
genau vor 45 Jahren war die Welt eine
andere
8848 Meter über dem Meer dorthin wo die
Luft dünn wird ohne Sauerstoffflasche
das hatte bis dato niemand geschafft
dann kam er Reinhold Messner und zeigt
es allen Ärzte hatten berechnet eine
Besteigung des Everest ohne Sauerstoff
unmöglich Messner und sein
österreichischer Kollege Peter Habeler
beweisen es geht doch
der Gipfel ist nah am 8 mai 1978
Reinhold Messner und Peter Habeler sind
bereits auf 8000 Metern Höhe doch der
Tag beginnt mit heftigem Sturm auf dem
Everest
das war sehr kalt wirklich sehr kalt
windig und in der Früh auch noch leicht
so mit Schlieren bedeckt wir haben sogar
wir haben uns angeschaut soll man nicht
8.848 Meter fast ohne Hilfe und Gepäck
für ihren Minimalismus sind die beiden
schon damals berühmt und die
Sauerstoffflaschen waren sowieso viel zu
schwer
so ein Stahlflaschen die die
darmflaschen hat noch nicht gegeben die
waren wirklich heavy und die hat sechs
Kilo oder vielleicht mehr als 6 Kilo
vollgefüllt und wir haben nichts zu
tragen gehabt also das hat uns geholfen
trotzdem zweifelt die Mehrheit der
Bergsteiger und Wissenschaftler
ohnmächtig oder verrückt würden Messner
und Habeler dort oben ohne Sauerstoff er
als den Gipfel zu erreichen doch ihr
ganz eigener Alpinstil sollte von
Vorteil sein
von Reinhold Messner weiß man eben aus
einer Messung kurz nach der
Erstbesteigung dass seine
Ausdauerfähigkeit die maximale
Sauerstoffaufnahme für den Muskel eher
einem Sprinter entsprochen hat der
tatsächlich kurze Maximalkraft
aufbringen muss das begünstigt einen
Aufstieg auf einen hohen Berg und dann
endlich erreichen die beiden den Gipfel
Messner schafft es zuerst nach oben
greift zur Kamera fängt an Peter Habeler
zu filmen
am Beginn wo wir angekommen waren am
Gipfel haben wir uns beide nur hingelegt
und geweint wieder Peter schon gesagt
hat und dann haben wir fotografiert wir
haben uns kam unterhalten weil die Luft
nicht dazu gereicht hat
das Foto gemacht dann bin ich zu dir und
holen aber dann brauche ich wieder
unruhig habe und
ich habe irgendwann auch erwähnt ich
dachte ich bin in den Zillertaler Bering
also ein bisschen mehr schuhke war ich
schon eine Kondition Reinhold reden aber
ich war schon ein bisschen weggetreten
am Ende gelingt Ihnen der Beweis dass
auch der höchste Berg der Welt ohne
Sauerstoffflaschen zu schaffen ist
heute hinterlässt der
expeditionstourismus seine Spuren auf
dem Everest Stau in der Todeszone ist
nicht mehr ungewöhnlich allein in dieser
Frühjahrssaison haben Nepals Behörden
mehr als 450 Genehmigungen für den
Aufstieg vergeben so viele wie noch nie
und die Buchen einfach einen Trip zum
everlust das ist immer noch anstrengend
das ist immer noch gefährlich aber es
hat nichts mit Pionierarbeit zu tun die
Erinnerung an Reinhold Messners und
Peter habelers Aufstieg zum höchsten
Gipfel der Welt sie wird die Zeit
überstehen und die Pioniere von heute
müssen sich neue Abenteuer suchen
Christian rufus hat noch einen
ausführlichen Film dazu gemacht der
weiterhin Erinnerungen schwägt den gibt
es in der ZDF Mediathek zu sehen und von
einem der auch mit 78 noch Touren in
Himalaya Basislager unternimmt noch ein
Tipp für alle die ohne Handy nicht
verreisen können
Abenteuer sind nur möglich sagt Reinhold
Messner wenn es keine ununterbrochene
Kommunikation nach Hause gibt
mit diesen Worten sagen wir danke fürs
Interesse heute ja und gegen 23:35 Uhr
meldet sich hier Christopher Wehrmann
mit unserem heute-journal-update vom
gesamten Team auf den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hinter den Kameras ein
angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend dazwischen zwei Hochs
entwickelt sich hier über dem Atlantik
und über Großbritannien eine
eindrucksvolle wolkenspirale das ist das
Tief soltan das hat den Wirklichkeit
nicht nur ein Zentrum sondern derer
gleich 3 und das bedeutet
Regenschauer und auch Gewitter die davon
Westen zu uns hereinziehen mit diesen
Regenschauern und Gewittern haben wir es
auch in der Nacht zu tun vor allen
Dingen hier im Westen Deutschlands die
letzten Gewitter verabschieden sich
schnell Richtung Nordsee auch am
Alpenrand kann es einige Schauer geben
im Osten ist es dagegen klar und da wird
es dann auch kalt da sinken die
Temperaturen noch sechs bis drei Grad
unter den dichteren Wolken im Westen
bleibt es deutlich milder mit 14 bis 10
Grad und die Höchsttemperatur morgen
liegen zwischen 16 Grad in der Eifel und
23 Grad hier in Thüringen und auch
morgens das Wetter komplett zwei geteilt
im Osten von der Ostseeküste bis zur
Donau scheint die Sonne strahlt ganz
anders sieht's im Westen aus der regnet
es kräftig es sind doch einzelne
Gewitter dabei da werden sie die Sonne
kaum zu Gesicht bekommen bei Südostwind
am Mittwoch erreichen die Regenfälle
dann auch den Osten der Donnerstag wird
wechselhaft und dann Freitag kommt dann
im Nordosten schon wieder die Sonne zum
Vorschein an den Temperaturen ändert
sich wenig bei 12 bis 22 Grad aber bis
zum Ende des Monats wird es dann doch
deutlich wärmer wie sich am Trend für
München sehen können dann geht's
Richtung
25°, das klingt danach Sommer guten
Abend